low-income apartment complex is in need
of some serious repairs to their heating
system according to property managers at
Hebron Apartments this has been an
ongoing issue for the past year now
they're asking the community for help
Madison Kimbrough spoke with those
affected and filed this story earlier
tonight
to not be able to take any kind of
warmth in your showers is something that
you can't put a finger on I've been kind
of like taking
like like a cold showers you know it's
like in and out with the colder weather
now upon us tenants at Hebron apartments
on Las Vegas Boulevard are struggling to
stay warm that's because their water
heater and boiler are out of commission
he brought a low-income housing complex
for veterans homeless and seniors has
struggled to stay afloat ever since
taking over the property a year ago
Meredith Spriggs of Caridad charity the
non-profit that manages the property
says with these repairs it's been an
ongoing struggle We inherited some
problems when we took over this property
so we are trying to find a motor for our
Boiler Room we've been struggling to
find parts and then we are trying to get
help to get our hot water heater rooms
restored retired vet bill Monroe who has
lived on the property for eight years
says he just tries to make do but it can
be hard with no heat to come home to
noting that the boiler never seems to
work consistently this particular boiler
over here just I don't know it has a
quick shelf life they just seem to go
through them one after another you know
the complex has three hot water units
and one boiler as of now one water
heater has been fixed but the two others
are still not working Meredith is asking
the community for donations of funds but
also parts to get the heat up and
running again
he brought houses 123 different people
with 40 of those residents being
veterans if you'd like to donate money
or parts you can call or show up to
their Las Vegas Boulevard location the
nonprofit also looking for clothes and
blanket donations this time of year